elle n'a rien ne prédestinait n'est que
le johnson à voir le jour en plein hiver
en gaspésie où sa mère travaillait comme
médecin car son père a grandi aux
bahamas
sa mère en jamaïque crs quand même mon
bébé est le bébé de noël de la gaspésie
après huit ans à gaspé la famille revit
à montréal n'est que le skandia outreman
et fréquente une des meilleures écoles
privées de wes manque aux primaires il
est le seul élève noir de l'école il
sera aussi le seul noir dans l'équipe
québécoise des échecs ses premières
passions à l'âge du jeu n'était pas
aussi consciente du rôle de la race dans
la société mais que le se découvre un
racisme plus ouverts à l'université
princeton
je me souviens un jour lorsqu'un
professeur à princeville a utilisé un
vocabulaire raciste dans une nasse
la majorité des étudiants voire sur le
campus moi inclus ne se sont pas santé
bienvenue je pense que beaucoup plus ni
crédit aux états unis à princeton
la prestigieuse université un lourd
passé ces neuf premiers présidents et
beaucoup de ses professeurs étaient
propriétaires d'esclaves qui pouvait
même être vendu sur le campus
l'institution aura pris deux cent
soixante quatorze ans pour décerner à un
noir le titre de major de promotion un
honneur réservé aux meilleurs élèves qui
allie réussite académique et engagement
social sur le fait que ça ait pris 274
on a le malheur de formation droit qu'il
reste encore beaucoup de travail à faire
avec les histoires de princes tonnes oui
je pense qu'il ya aussi un autre élément
démontrer aux autres aux autres jeunes
noirs que c'est possible c'est possible
d'accomplir n'importe quel ce que vous
aurez comme objectif
michelle obama écrit sur twitter cet
ancien de princeton est tellement fière
de toi nique le mot rialet de développer
des systèmes informatiques qui
combattent des inégalités dans l'accès
aux soins de santé par exemple qui a
réussi à diminuer dès les injustices qui
existe déjà au lieu de cris des roses la
justice quand et quel sera terminé son
doctorat ou va-t-il lancer son
entreprise de recherche
j'imagine que à cause du
multiculturalisme beaucoup plus fort au
canada le jeune diplômé écrira une page
d'histoire dimanche
en prononçant le discours de sa
promotion lors d'une cérémonie virtuel
n'est que le sera à la maison à montréal
avec sa famille
je n'ai pas encore pleurer mais je sais
pas qu'est ce qui devait arriver le 31
mai ici sophie langlois radio canada
montréal
[Musique]